today in the world more people die from
eating too much than from eating too
little for the first time in history I
think the last data for the World Health
Organization says that about three
million people die each year from
obesity and related diseases compared to
1 million people that die from
starvation and malnutrition at the same
time for the first time in history more
people die from old age than from
infectious diseases and also for the
first time in history more people commit
suicide each year that the total number
of death from war crime and terrorism
put together which is very good news not
a suicide beta0 no the fact that
affected yes yes it's like no it's not
it's suicide when that it's that death
from violence have gone down today let's
say for the people here in this room I
think it's safe to say that McDonald's
and Coca Cola paused a far greater
threat to your life than al Qaeda in the
Islamic state the chance that you
the chance that you will die from eating
too much at McDonald's is about a
thousand times higher and this is not an
exaggeration this is statistics it's
about a thousand times higher than the
chance we'll be killed by some Islamic
state terrorism attack